is it possible to create
molecules that start approaching this
question
that we started this conversation which
which is the origin of life so to start
to create molecules that have
life-like qualities so
have the replication have like complex
start to create complex organisms so we
have done this with the oxides i talked
about earlier the molybdenum oxides and
the rings and the bulls and the problem
is that what they are they do
they auto catalytically enhance one
another so they would
i guess you would call it
self-replication but because there's
limited
um function
and mutation
they're pretty dumb so they don't do
very much
so
i think
the prospect of us being able to
engineer
a nano material a nano material life
form in the short term like i said
earlier my aim is to do this of course i
mean i'm you know on one hand i'm saying
it's impossible on the other hand i'm
saying i'm doing it so which is it lee
you know it's like
uh well like i think we can do it but
only in the robot so the causal chain
that's gonna allow it is in the robot
these particles if they do start to
self-replicate the systems can be so
fragile
that i don't think anything
dangerous will come out and it doesn't
mean we shouldn't treat them as
potentially you know
um
i mean i don't want to scare people like
gain a function we're going to produce
stuff that comes out our number one kill
switch is that we always try to search
a space of
objects that
don't exist in our it don't exist in the
environment so even if something got out
it just would die immediately it's like
making a silicon life form or something
or you know which is the opposite of uh
oftentimes gain of functional research
just focused on like how do you get a
dangerous thing to be closer to
something that works with humans yeah so
they'll have a jump to humans so that's
the one that's one good mode to operate
on is
always try to operate on
chemical entities that are very
different than the the kind of chemical
environment that humans operate in yeah
and also i mean i'll say something
dramatic
which may not be
may not be true so i should be careful
if let's say we did discover a new
living system and it was made out of a
shadow biosphere
and we just released it in the
environment who cares it's going to use
different stuff
it'll just live
just live yeah i i found one of my
biggest fantasies is actually is like a
planet that's basically half in the sun
it doesn't rotate right and
and
you have two different origins of life
on that planet
and they don't share the same chemistry
yeah
and then they only wait time they
recognize each other when they become
intelligent they go well what's that
moving yeah
i i wonder if they co-evolve and that's
fascinating i mean so one fascinating
thing to do is exactly what you were
saying which is a life bomb yeah which
is like
try to focus on atmospheres or um
chemical conditions of other planets and
try within
this kind of uh uh
exploration optimization system try to
discover
life forms
that can work in those conditions and
then you
send those life forms over there
see what kind of stuff they build up
like you can do like a large scale
it's kind of a safe
physical environment to do large-scale
experiments it's another planet yeah so
look i'm gonna say something quite
contentious i mean elon wants to go to
mars i think it's brilliant wants to go
to mars but i would counter that and say
is elon just obsessed with getting
humanity off earth or what about just
technology so if we do technology so so
elon either needs to take a computer to
mask he needs to manufacture drugs right
on demand right because you zero cost
payload and all that stuff is just code
or what we do is we actually say hang on
it's quite hard for humans to survive on
mars why don't we write a series of
origin life algorithms where we put our
cult embed our culture in it right this
is a very riddly spot prometheus right
yeah which is a terrible film by the way
but anyway
uh um and dump it on mars and just
terraform mars and what we do is we
evolve life on mars that is suited to
life on mars yeah rather than brute
forcing human life on mars
you